social media is not different from
society not separate from it problem of
governing social media is exactly the
same thing as governing a society you
need a right form of government you need
a legal system ultimately you need
representation and all these issues
right it's not just a moderation team
and uh the same thing is also to for the
brain what is the government of the
brain that emerges in what Gary idman
calls neural Darin ISM among different
forms of organization in the mind until
you have a model of a self-organizing
agent that discovers that what it's
Computing is driving the behavior of an
agent in the real world and it covers a
first- person perspective and so on